ومشاهدينا لهذا الخبر مره اخرى العاجل
بحسب اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي عن مصدر امني
اسقاط مسير له الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم
جنين وحول مجاهدا في هذا العجل اعود الى
وليد ال العمري وليد هل من تفاصيل بشان
هذا الخبر
عاده مثل هذه الطائرات المسيرات تصاحب
بقوات الاحتلال في عملياتها فعمليه سقوطها
من عدمها هي امر وارد ولكن ليس بالضروره
ان تكون جراء اصابه قد يكون امر عارض لكن
المهم في هذه همم هذا العدوان اليوم على
مخيم جنين هي الطريقه التي تمت به وفق
شهود العيان جيش الاحتلال كل ما صرح به هو
انه ليس لديه اصابات او اضرار حتى الساعه
لكن قد يتضح خلال الفتره المقبله مائده
هناك اصابات في صفوفه الطريقه التي دخلوا
فيها هم حسب شهود العيان دخلوا متخفينا
بالزي المدني اي ما يعرفون بالمستعربين
داخل سياره لنقل الالبان حسب ما افادنا به
شهود العيان وهؤلاء انتشروا معه وصول همم
فورا الاليات المدرعه باعداد الكبيره حيث
احتل القناصه اسطح المباني وبدات
الاشتباكات لكن القوات الكوماندوز كانت تت
يوجد على الارض وقد عملت على سيطره عليها
لذلك دارت هذه الاشتباكات في اكثر من محور